Hey, I'm Abella danger. And I'm here to answer the Internet's question.
[Inaudible].
Would you rather give up sex or porn for one year?
Um, I would rather kind of isn't it the same porn and sex?
No. Most of us it's super different, very different. Um,
I guess something I watch sex is something that hopefully.
I guess I would have to give a porn for one year because I like having sex in
private a little bit more shooting porn is really fun,
but you give out like your money for a year. Okay. But money is only, you know,
it can only give you so much happiness.
If you could make one movie character real to date you,
who would it be? I guess I would really love to date 20 stark.
Like I'm obsessed with this character. He's just like such an too. Like,
I love it.
[Inaudible].
Who's the hottest celebrity. You think you have a shot with?
If they got to know you? Um, I think Michael B. Jordan,
for sure. He's really hot.
And I feel like he'd be into me. Um,
would you rather have ugly shoes or ugly underwear for the rest of your life?
Definitely ugly under underwear. Like I love sneakers.
Like I do not even like, with heels,
like sneakers are my life and I wear like granny panties.
So that's like already, no, I mean, yeah, no, I don't.
[Inaudible].
It's pretty panties though. Like, it's just like, whatever, like, I don't know,
like, but sneakers is like my obsession because eventually we're all naked.
Like that's what matters, you know, you're, you're stripped down to nothing.
Would you rather be married to someone extremely attractive or be extremely
attractive?
I guess I would rather be married to someone extremely attractive because I'll
be like, wow, there's such an honor.
You're like extremely attractive and you're married to me and I'm like,
not attractive. Yeah.
Let's talk your mind your back. Like how the hell did she get hurt?
It doesn't make any sense.
Walden. They're going to be like, there must be something really amazing,
but she was really good at sucking Dick. Like, I don't know, like,
they're going to just be wondering and that's just going to kill them. You know,
they're going to be dying with jealousy and her love it.
Would you rather a guy last 30 seconds or one hour actually rather a guy last 30
seconds. Cause I think it's like the biggest compliment ever.
Like I've had guys like last, like not even a minute. And I'm like, Oh,
I love that. Like, wow. Like, I mean, you come really early.
Like I kind of find it offensive. If a guy takes a long time to come, I'm like,
what's wrong with me? So like.
So many guys at home are like [inaudible].
Um, would you rather be a bad kisser or give bad head,
this is so like hard because I'm really good at both.
[Inaudible].
I started guys are always like, you give like the best blow jobs ever.
So, but I like, no, I have to give up good kissing.
Cause like giving head is like an art form. Like it's so much fun. So.
Most passionate you've gotten.
I love it. Like that's I'm like completely bisexual.
Cause I like both so much. Whoa.
A pigs orgasm lasts for over 30 minutes.
Elian can have sex over 50 times per day. Which would you rather be in?
I would definitely rather be a pig because I always say the size part about an
orgasm is how short it lasts. Like I wish it lasted even like a minute,
like the actual orgasm feeling.
So would love for an orgasm to last 30 minutes. I might pass out. But
would you rather live in a world where everyone,
but you is male or female?
This.
Is so hard. Um.
You're the first bisexual answer. Yeah. This is so hard.
You have the weight of the whole sexual orientation. This is hard.
It is hard because I love my girlfriends so much.
But imagine like the entire world,
like we would all get her period at the same time. So I'm like, Hmm.
You all saved.
If like I'll do it with all girls.
If all the girls are like super hot and I would hide in my house when we all
have our periods. Um,
do you think there's more porn stars or murders in the world? Um.
What do you, what do you consider a porn star?
Um, someone that like does porn.
So like if I, if I just made one video right now, put more star.
No, I don't know. I don't think you have earned the term points.
Like you should know.
I don't know. I think everyone can be a porn site. That's a great thing.
You can like make like 10. Yeah. She's important. Sorry.
She's she's in the top 20 of porn hub. Like you're porn. Sorry.
Like you can be other things too. Like I'm important to her, but I model too.
Like, but you're still a porn star. Like don't forget. What got you there,
sweetie.
I see.
See, I think there's more porn stars in the world than murders.
I mean over all of the time then I guess murders,
but like currently, I don't know. This was really her question.
I really don't know how many murders.
If you're, if you're saying everyone who's ever had sex on camera.
There's a lot of like amateur porn stars. Like yeah.
There's more important SARS, which just, you know, that makes me happy murders.
Aren't cool. Starting today. If you get $10,000 for every day, you don't.
How many days could you go without jerking off.
That's hard. Um.
Is harder for guys or girls?
Uh, I don't know. I can only speak for myself and I love masturbating so much.
So like you do it multiple times a day. So that'd be 10 grand,
probably like two days then it would not be worth it to me anymore.
I would just be like, I need to do this. I'll so angry.
Would you rather say on a cake and eat a Dick or sit on a
Dick and eat a cake?
I would rather sit on a cake and eat a Dick, but like, you know,
like suck it right? Not like.
Eat it. Okay.
Yeah. I'd rather, I'd rather.
Rather sit on a cake and eat a day because I really like second day.
So we got through that. What's the weirdest thing you have masturbated too.
Oh my God.
Um, my God, um, my God, uh, be honest.
Uh, it was like
anime porn and it was like a squid type thing.
Having sex with like an Asian girl.
It was like one of these things I swear, right after it.
Had an orgasm, I felt like so ashamed. I was like, what is wrong with me?
Actually?
I it's like, it's like, if you make a sex tape, right,
you obviously want to watch it again, relive it.
So it's like me watching my sex tape and I'm like, Oh,
I came so hard there that's so high. Like, you know,
would you rather know when you're going to die or how you're going to die?
They're both kind of really morbid. Um,
I guess I would rather know when I'm going to die and not how,
because if I knew how then I'd be crying, trying to like prevent it.
But if I knew when then I would just like live my life extra to the fullest up
until then. Um, who is the celebrity you most want to see in a sex tape?
So many hot girls. Um.
No, I'm like, I'm not going to waste this on a dude. Like I need to see a girl.
Uh, I guess Scarlett Johansson's like, I would love to see her, no porno.
Like she has such a shapely bottom.
I feel like I have to, she's a lady. I have to talk.
Talk to her like she's a lady.
Would you rather be an extremely good looking paralyzed person or a
hideous looking person that can walk? I mean,
I'd rather be a hideous looking person that can walk honestly.
Cause I like walking.
Come loudly.
Every time you fart or fart loudly, every time you come,
I'd rather come loudly. Every time I fart, honestly,
because I would just be great. Like he far.
And then you come like both are such cool things to do.
Would you rather give the first 90% of a blow job and not the last
temp or the last 10%? Um, yeah,
I would rather give the first 98% of a job.
Cause like feeling it grow in my mouth and like the beginning excitement and
like the Oh, like saving, like, I don't know. It's the first 90%.
Well, there's so many questions about second negative thinking.